-Our next guest is a talented
director, writer, and actor
you know from movies
like "Clerks,"
"Jay and Silent Bob Strike
Back," and "Dogma."
His highly anticipated film
"Clerks III"
is in select theaters now.
Let's take a look.
-I had a heart attack?
-No, that's not what I said.
You misunderstood me.
-Oh, thank Christ.
-You're having a heart attack
right now, as we speak.
A massive one.
So we have to act
pretty quickly.
I just wish
I wasn't so hung over.
I'm kidding.
I'm gonna go get all glammed up
for our big date,
and I'll see you in the O.R.
Look at me.
-Uh-huh.
-Everything's gonna be
fine, alright?
-Good. Alright.
-He's not gonna make it.
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Kevin Smith,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, my friend.
-So good to be here, man.
-I was telling the audience,
I know you want to check on it.
-Free commercial, right there.
-Free commercial.
-When you did it earlier,
I was like,
"We're gonna sell
so much more weed."
Thank you.
-There you go. Good.
I want this to be
a place for you
to promote your marijuana.
-My wares.
-Yeah.
-I was out smoking one of those
today in New York
and had a very quintessential
New York moment.
I was walking around
Lincoln Center, smoking,
remembering things
that I've done there
over the years
with movies and whatnot.
And a car
went around the corner,
and somebody yelled out at me,
"Kevin Smith wannabe!"
and kept going.
I didn't get to tell him like,
"I am him."
Alright, I got an agenda, so I
want to do something real quick.
I see you getting ready
to talk-show.
No. We got something to do.
-You're in charge. Okay.
-Number one,
I brought you some comic books.
I made a new comic book.
I brought you one to read.
It's called "Maskerade."
It comes out already -- today.
One bag-and-board to save,
one to read.
-Thank you.
You're a comic-book fan.
You appreciate -- This is the
one I'm going to read.
This is the one I'm gonna save
to preserve its value.
-Absolutely, man. Invest.
-There you go. Great.
-Put it away for your kids to go
to college off of that one book.
-Okay, great.
One of the
lesser colleges, maybe.
-Probably. A community college,
a little CC.
Nothing wrong with --
I went to CC.
-Yeah.
-We can't all go to
Northwestern.
-Yeah. Oh, thank you.
-Some of our parents
had to work and whatever.
So, I've got a new movie coming
out, "Clerks III."
It is literally playing tonight.
Fathom Events is showing it
for one week only,
from tonight till Sunday night,
so you can see it
on the weekend.
It's a wonderful movie.
Bring tissues, both
for excitement, if you will,
and also for tears.
It's very emotional.
-Oh, great. Okay, gotcha.
-Yeah, so all the fluids
are coming out on this picture.
-That's very exciting.
-If you can't go see it in a
Fathom Events screening,
you can come see it with me.
I'm touring the country with it.
I was just at the
Warner Theatre in Washington?
-Yeah. Yeah.
We did our show there.
That's right.
We did a week of shows there.
-So, I go out with the movie
and I tour with it
and then I do Q&A afterwards.
It's amazing.
Basically, every night,
it's like going to a church
where I'm both the priest
and Jesus at the same time.
-Wow.
-So, please,
engage with "Clerks III."
It's a wonderful movie.
It's about me almost dying.
It's kind of
the story of my life.
So, let's get rid of
the sales pitch.
This is what I came to do.
I only make movies so I can come
here and play with Seth.
-Okay.
-I wrote a bit for us to do.
[ Laughter ]
Yes, absolutely.
I'm a huge fan of the show and I
watch it all the time and stuff.
So, one of my favorite things
about you on this show
is when you do
impressions, impersonations.
-Well, you have
a bad ear for it.
-No, I have a great ear for it.
I think it's funny as hell
to see you
try so hard, you know?
-Okay.
-So...
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, I wrote this bit
for us to do.
It's based on --
One time,
you were talking about --
You did a run of jokes about
going to Impressions Camp.
-I did, yeah.
-Yes.
So, this bit is called --
You're familiar with
"The Twelve Days of Christmas."
-Yes.
-This is "The Ten Days of
Impressions Camp."
I tightened it up,
because TV, and we got to go.
-Okay, great. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We don't have time for 12.
-No, not 12.
But this is going --
-We're not going to do
any of the things I planned --
-Not at all, not at all.
-Okay, great.
-Okay.
-Such a waste of time.
-Okay, good, good, good.
-This is -- Now, I'll let you
pre-look at it,
but, also, I'll talk
so I can set people up.
The idea here is, Seth does
a certain amount of impressions.
This song will require him to do
those impressions,
first one at a time,
and because of the
repetitive nature of
"Twelve Days of Christmas,"
he has to keep switching
impressions all the time.
So, I figure he's an
"SNL" kid, man.
He's limber.
He can do this sort of thing.
-Yeah, yeah, that show is --
That show is improvised. Yeah.
-Yeah, absolutely.
He doesn't get enough --
You get credit for being, like,
a brilliant show host and stuff,
but I don't think you get
the credit for being
a performer you deserve.
So I want to put you up
on a pedestal
so everyone can see
what you can do.
-Okay, gotcha.
You know, a little heads-up
next time.
-No, not at all.
-Sure.
-That's the --
They asked me like,
"Do you want us
to give it to Seth?"
I was like, "No, I want to give
it to him on the stage,"
because I think
you're that good.
-Alright. Wow.
-And if you're wrong,
it works either way.
Okay, so, I'll do the --
Obviously, I'm the Kev part,
and you are every part
that's not Kev.
-Gotcha. Okay.
-So I'm gonna set him up with --
lyrically.
If you guys want to "oompa oompa
oompa" along, you can.
Don't -- I know you're a pro.
I'm sorry.
I was giving you notes.
But, you know, just so we have
a little background -- or not.
Otherwise,
it's a cappella and dry.
It's gonna sound like
high school.
-Okay.
-Alright, here we go.
[ Clears throat ]
♪ On the first day of
Impressions Camp,
Bane did send to me ♪
[ As Bane ]
-♪ Batman in a porno movie ♪
-♪ On the second day of
Impressions Camp,
Vince Vaughn sent to me ♪
-♪ Two buddy-buddies
and Batman in a porno movie ♪
-So far, so good.
So far, so good.
♪ On the third day of
Impressions Camp,
Owen Wilson sent to me ♪
-♪ Three ah-geezes,
two buddy-buddies,
and Batman in a porno movie ♪
-We're good. We're good.
-♪ On the fourth day of
Impressions Camp,
MyPillow Guy gave to me ♪
-♪ Tickets to Da Bears,
three ah-geezes,
two buddy-buddies,
and Batman in a porno movie ♪
-♪ On the fifth day of -- ♪
We're halfway through.
♪ On the fifth day of
Impressions Camp,
Trump did send to me ♪
-♪ Five golden bells,
tickets to Da Bears,
three ah-geezes,
two...
[ Laughter ]
two buddy-buddies,
and Batman in a porno movie ♪
This is why people hate
"The Twelve Days of Christmas."
-Yes. This is my favorite,
'cause this is
my favorite character you do.
♪ On the sixth day of
Impressions Camp,
a Southern lawyer sent to me ♪
-♪ The Mason-Dixon Line,
five golden bells,
tickets to Da Bears,
three ah-geez, two -- ♪
Just go to the seventh.
-No! Do it. Finish it.
-Oh, my God.
-I'm a director. Listen to me.
Finish it.
-♪ Two...♪
♪ Two buddy-buddies,
and Batman in a porno movie ♪
-♪ On the seventh day of
Impressions Camp,
Pacino sent to me ♪
-♪ Seven salutations,
the Mason-Dixon Line,
five golden bells,
tickets to Da Bears,
three ah-geezes,
two buddy-buddies,
and -- ♪
Oh, no, that's right.
♪ Batman in a porno movie ♪
I'm falling away.
-Finds the voice every time.
Look at the sweat coming out.
You haven't worked this hard
in years, kid.
-No.
-♪ On the eighth day of
Impressions Camp,
Lindsey Graham sent to me ♪
-♪ Eight weeks of mee-maw,
seven salutations,
the Mason-Dixon Line,
five golden bells,
tickets to Da Bears,
three ah-geez,
two buddy-buddies,
and Bat--
♪ Batman in a porno movie ♪
Oh, I've lost my Bane.
-You'll find it. You'll find it.
I have faith in you.
-This is gonna need a lot of
edits when this is on air.
-No way.
They play the whole thing.
-♪ On the ninth day of
Impressions Camp,
Shoemaker said to me ♪
-♪ Hey, I'm Mikey the Shoe,
eight weeks of mee-maw,
seven salutations,
the Mason-Dixon Line,
five golden bells,
tickets to Da Bears,
ah-geez,
two buddy-buddies,
♪ Batman in a porno movie ♪
The Bane's falling apart.
Alright, the last one.
-Here we go, kids.
We've reached the end.
♪ On the tenth day of
Impressions Camp,
Steve from "Sex and the City"
said to me ♪
-[ Laughs ]
♪ Ten more Mirandas? ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Oh, I'm Mikey the Shoe,
eight weeks of mee-maw,
seven salutations,
the Mason-Dixon Line,
five golden bell--
five golden bells ♪
First time I got it right.
-Excellent, excellent.
-♪ Tickets to Da Bears,
three ah-geezes,
two buddy-buddies,
and -- ♪
Alright, wait. Hold on.
♪ Batman -- ♪
There it is.
♪ Batman in a porno movie ♪
-Give it up for Seth! Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, God!
-Well...
Thanks for having me.
-We'll be right back with
somebody else.